sì sì sì
tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo video
sono fa vigente ed oggi siamo tornati su
wells che come tratto ragazzi siamo al
nuovo parta 5 esimo 95 episodi di f
intanto c'è anche 95 per cento in bossi
ball perché l'hanno fatto proprio a
posto ha visto che sanno che questo al
95esimo episodio l'altra ragazzi io sono
andato nel 95 quindi ragazzi oggi è
tutto 95 a caso infatti qua c'è 9 equa
c'è il 9 45 59 però al contrario fa 95
ragazzi aproteica gatte partiamo con
l'impossible visto che ancora non ho
visto visto che ancora non ho visto
imparato a parlare come parlava vj
soprattutto a morire come muore non ha
vagato a te l'arpione che è entrato
nell'anno per altro discorso
bene i ragazzi e potenza a postissimo
quante volte ci può provare tipo
probabilmente 95 niente ragazzi oggi non
c'è verso già capito che tanto non è
giornata però o come lo p er culo
importante partire ragazzi poi
chissenefrega the king the king
marrakech
ho preso
avevo preso ha compreso arpione però non
so effettivamente quanto mi con
benissimo ecco ragazzi non ce la farà
mai ma se se tipo faccio così mi tiro su
da solo ora la bomba come sapremo asi
stronzo dagli ragazzi noi cosa fa e cosa
fai steve
come sai che questo è più difficile
dell'imposta ho preso un arpione cosa
che penso è successo
[Musica]
fermi cosa come quando lavora che non ho
capito come ho fatto ma non importa va
bene così devoto fixed dare un volto che
da una vita che non ne faccio uno
decente però deve essere decente non ne
vale cagate tipo questa che due palle
tanto due palle ci avevamo già per
l'amor di dio jackpot inizia a lanciare
cosa a caso vai veloce
qualcuno mi farà vincere neanche una
porcata cos'è chi cazzo è quello
[Musica]
dai porca ladro o niente mi chiamo raga
impossibile
no io l'ho preso come un fatto aprendo
ok ok no
[ __ ] a pranzo allora non c'è beh
non c'è qua quante volte ho preso il
jackpot
fatemi capire deve andare su victory
quel quanto è difficile dio mio a secret
click yourself quindi oddio mi ha
lanciato tante palline perché ora per
quale motivo anzi porca vacca jackpot
allora iniziò non c'era
come come capcom e che un'ora e mezza a
lanciare palle e poi anche un cosino e
vinco come cazzo è successo cioè io
ragazzi ve lo dico noi non ci arriviamo
al centesimo episodio di fv se lo
distruggo prima al sito
ve lo giuro porsche carrera con nonno
ciak io non ho capito una cosa che mi
perdono chacha le macchine belle come
mai questa cosa ogni volta diego il
tizio anzi ancora di riprendere i
capelli tu come pensi di guidare meglio
di me a gaione vita incredibile tanto
c'è una barriera di angurie spiegazioni
la barriera di angurie oddio no no no
che mi recupera vai vai bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye come lo prende nel delle
tare e ciao fratello arrivato già in
texas
ragazzi vi posso assicurare che nessuna
anguria e stata maltrattata in questo
livello tranne una
vabbè una e basta blender è uno di quei
frullatori soliti iv rolli in un nonno
ciak per cortesia
no perché non sa che vedo perfetto no
però gli altri due non erano compresi
nonno ciak di un bandai e è più ananas
non so per quale motivo parto ho detto
ai nas perché mi avete tirato ma anguria
e l'anguria di prima ragazzi si sta
vendicando però apriamo una porta si può
andare avanti
tanto ragazzi la tizia con l'ananas
intesa sembra che balli qualcosa li
tropicale
e io mi sto godendo la scena così
sdraiato perfetto start blender quindi
si può iniziare a cotto e il frullato
ragazzi cotto e frullato adesso ho
capito che cazzo se magna merluzzo da
parte diventare così potere ex i cazzi
però gli zero gene che grazie frate
grazie attimino che vado un attimo al
cesso a vomitare e arrivo a finisce
l'altro come me lo voglio bene sto coso
col culo cool all'aria fantastico
proprio della serie me lo mettete con
l'imbuto matrix epic
vabbè tanto di matrix abbiamo fatto
infatti dato su tutti uguali ma brava
nonno dopo anni di è primis ha ancora
mai capito come fare matrix non ce l'ho
fatto dio la scopa gli reporter a mio
figlio bellissimo
il mondo dei misteri world of mystery
cosa mi devo aspettare si è già visto di
tutto in pochi minuti cos'è un horror
bello frontale sembra meglio dell'inizio
di auto per l'amor di dio allora se io
premo il tasto in avanti tu devi muovere
il culetto zio capisci ti muovi fratte
por che vado a saltare perché giusta
giustamente io non riesco a superare già
perso un piede non ho fatto un metro ma
come è possibile sta cosa è partito
benissimo sta livello e per l'amor di
dio ai a tema le è il livello più
merdoso di partenza che abbia mai visto
vigna è partito veramente da schifo ok
la pena prima prima la partenza faceva
troppo schifo in un caso governo vabbè
dai capita tutti i giorni di farsi
cadere un albero in faccia giusta frate
farmi capire perché dovrebbe cadere a
era caduto dalla parte sbagliata certo
dando sono io che gioco sembra la solita
sfiga you have to get up the flight to
get di ex shop metri da un night work e
genius come baie di prendi lascia prendi
lascia lo so che un controsenso però
prendi la famiglia per come faccia
prendere madonna che schifo di uomo anzi
devi prendere lascia non è che ti fa
chissà cosa no vabbè vabbè [ __ ] va
e due ore e mezza che prova a prendere
staccando cliccarci sopra
ma sei serio ma cazzo ma di melo
che scassato la sto cazzo di mouse
quando l'hanno introdotta in f.de
morisse il criceto o ragazzi non importa
siamo andati avanti importante e questo
ha messo non è però vabbè andiamo avanti
c'è qualcos'altro che può fare salve io
prendo un po il sole qui se non ti
dispiace grazie tu vai pure negli inferi
allora ragazzi ci sono due tizi bene non
odio però come lo [ __ ] quanto lo fu
tutto soprattutto c'è un fiore ciao
devo andare avanti ed io siamo nelle
caverne di minecraft modo spontanei
zombie ho capito credo di essere entrato
nella tana del bianconiglio tipo alice
questo ascensore ha bisogno delle chiavi
per funzionare
ok va bene a devo andare proprio devo
seguire la freccia a quanto conto che ci
ha fatto bene sto livello grock lì con
il board to get the moto ok
devo sparito di adesso diventato call
call call of duty zombie e ho trovato la
chiave dell'ascensore amena chiave
quella dunque che bello non voglio
capire come mai funziona un ascensore in
una caverna proprio non ne ho idea ma
vabbè andiamo su perfetto ho trovato una
chiave che ci sono più chiari il suo
livello che in un invio horror cazzo
fantastico mi fate uscire da sa
raccapricciante caverna che dio mio
quella di batman in confronto e
gardaland possa dare un antico anzi
oddio perché ci sono delle meduse che
volano io non mi ricordo che le meduse
volano a quanto mi ricordo le meduse non
volano ragazzi prove mara sono caduto
nell'acqua ma perché altro non a fuoco
ragazzi io posso respirare sott'acqua
vai elmo salvati toulouse e quasi
salvato l'elmo regard lo faccio ceri qua
vai trascinati uomo trash non lo voglio
rifarmi livello non voglio rifarmi
livello non voglio rifarmi livello
prendi lo prendi lo brutto idiota piano
piano ho preso
ci ho messo un'ora e mezzo era che però
va beh oddio che stai facendo è un nuovo
massaggio schiena lo vendono sui media
shopping sta facendo se è una mossa di
danza questa che cazzo fai
ma cosa fa
ma [ __ ] a chi your bones occhi
loro boss non botto e non è facile ma è
bravo non lavora come si diverte
fam nei maroni l'ho presa di maroni
adesso c'è solo ai maroni adesso non c'è
più manco quelli tranche con the sun
contest da ubriaco cioè ho fatto
canestro perché sono mai mai mai padre
flessioni
12 34
da amy e vabbè dai e quella sensazione
che provo io quando faccio le flessioni
comunque solo agli addominali però va
bene che a soli facciamo un paio di miei
livelli visto che da un secolo che non
ne faccio neanche uno in prossimo oggi
mi sento di fare gli imposti con ragazzi
non so perché è stato sbagliato non è
giusto va bene anche con andy idioti che
merda fatemelo fare col recco con loro
perché mio dio ragazzi po che non vive
devo fare livelli decenti vero è invece
fa vj scontro ragazzi facciamo l'ultimo
perché voglio vedere uno su questo è uno
smalto decente nonno ciak mister barba
gillet ha come madre di hugo il nuovo
tricker del bmx park culona la svuota
supermercati luke stronzo petalo zoe
steve il riso irrisolti tori impossibile
va bene
grazie per aver dato un appellativo fake
e di non è il caso la gente quello che
fece dpa testa la spada
nell'anno perfetto ma anche il padre di
uk non manca solo un ragazzo bikers che
non prenderò mai tipo c'è ma che tiro di
merda ho fatto perfetto per far ovest a
8 finito per forza sto scherzando le ma
non prendere troppo alla lettera mondo
di queste cose
addio porca eva ma ce la fai a cadere
dritto dritto a quello doveva
dall'inizio complimenti per il tiro voto
5 e sapere prendermi dei consigli
derivati da creare grazie mille guarda
zio per me va bene anche così no non c'è
bisogno tanto ho già visto abbastanza
vecchio da ragazzi con quello che
episodio spero che vide vi sia piaciuto
siano quasi al 90 dio al 96 prossimo
siamo quasi al centesimo episodio forse
molti di voi sapranno cosa voglio fare
per il centesimo episodio ma non voglio
sperarlo spero che avete vi sia piaciuto
cose che vi è piaciuto un commento è un
mi piace anche a pagina di facebook e
com'era iniziato tale iniziale se lo
serve city sky ci davano prossimo video
belle ragazze